hey guys before I start the today's
topic I want announce a new giveaway in
which you have a chance to win $50
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
participate in this giveaway is simply
to be subscribed liked this video and
post comment on today's topic today I'm
going to talk about few theories about
Aria being dead and about the vase
wearing and portraying Aria ever since
the fight in the dark chamber took place
along with two more theories that
include both of already mentioned
characters this video is going to be
long and detailed so just sit back and
enjoy uh terraria survived multiple stab
wounds leaping out the window falling
down the stairs
apparently managing to defeat the waves
and upon jackin statement that there is
not a third chance upon saying that she
must die I still felt a need to say the
farewell to her mentor which makes no
sense to me a logical choice would be to
kill the wave and run away from bravo's
as well no aria came back to the house
so black and white that a face that is
apparently face of the wave which is
surprising that Aria could barely stand
not to mention fight and win against the
vase and on top of all of those tags are
also seemingly recovered from serious
wounds and blood loss in short amount of
time while some of us would tell that
lady Crain was of tremendous help Aria
might even kill her in that more than
short amount of time
some of us could also tell that Aria
played it very smart as she on purpose
headed to that dark chamber in a room in
which she hid her sword in a room that
had only one source of light a candle
Daria sliced as she estimated at her
chances of surviving or bigger as she
has been trained by the first sword of
Braavos biserial and also has been
taught to fight blinded while trying to
become a faceless man assassin gentleman
black and the next thing with solos
jackeen entering the Hall of faces where
he found out that Aria killed a vase
burp on Jackie not surprisingly happy
about Aria reclaiming her identity and
her intentions to go home which might be
a confirmation that Jackie was actually
Syrio Forel
could be a confirmation that from the
beginning Jackie wanted her to be
herself to be Arya Stark
if Jackie and truly is serial you might
wonder why did he send away for terraria
why did he led the way to almost kill
her the answer could be a theory in
which the wait didn't stab Aria but Jack
in varying arias phase which a few facts
might confirm
those facts are the Tarija who could
have used one of ASIS and high culture
identity as she has been using in order
to kill Walder Frey as she was aware of
the waves intentions to kill her but she
decided to be herself too surprisingly
walked calmly around Braavos and
searched for travel back to Westeros the
second fact is that she didn't have her
sword with her even though she was a
target for a faceless man and if this
wasn't enough for you to believe in the
story let's mention the last third fact
that is going in favor to this theory
which is Arya having a big amount of
money to afford a trip back to Westeros
and on top of all of this demanding too
late tomorrow instead to leave
immediately next what happened is even
more surprising as arya upon making a
deal she decided to walk around like a
tourist I mean yes she's leaning
tomorrow she probably wanted to see a
few historical sights for the last time
but she's not a tourist in addition she
was being hunted with all of those tags
being said I don't have anything to say
against those who support his theory it
would actually make a lot of sense if
Jackie was wearing Gary of space and
that they tested the wave vial on the
same time he said Daria and paid her
travel back to Westeros I'm aware that
most of you right now are questioning
the accuracy of this theory just as I
have been while thinking about it I'm
aware that most of you think that jackin
Kuna mayor arias face says she's alive
but you might be wrong back in the final
episode of season 5 there was a
seemingly jogging Kagari Aria space who
was standing just beside him that scene
confirms at least in my opinion that the
faceless man assassins can wear the face
of a person that is not dead a person
that is still alive as they might be
able to create a face to create some
kind of a mask from the other faces in
order to portray a man or woman that is
still alive the only thing that makes
this theory questionable is aria
statement that she referred to jackeen
after everything was done she said you
told her to kill me which means that
aria and the waves had that fight in the
dark room as Jackie didn't know who had
won and who had died until he entered
the Hall of faces but still according to
this theory it was jocking wearing arias
face who got stabbed instead of aria
to conclude this theory jaqen is
actually Syrio Forel he was wearing our
face in order to test the weight which
would explain why ru was calmly walking
around like a 2
without her sword and how are you I was
having a huge amount of money to pay for
her travel while are they only fought
against the wave withers sword in the
dark room if you want to hear more
details about a faceless man that first
face already criminal by the name of
jacking car gar is actually Syrio Forel
feel free to check it out in one of my
previous videos I have that made that
history that I mentioned a few moments
ago is pretty plausible but on the other
hand we should think about the theory
that has been floating around ever since
Arya killed waves ever since she said to
Jackie that your name is Arya Stark of
Winterfell and that she's going home
only joking reacted more than
surprisingly could it be that sorry I
didn't survive could it be that the
person that returned to the house of
black and white was the wave Berengaria
space well there's certainly a
possibility and the superior which I'm
going to consider and to talk about for
the next few minutes the wave just
Azaria had also been training to become
no.1
so perhaps by killing and becoming
Gardea she passed her test and became a
faceless man which would explain why the
wave was interested and was knowing
almost every single detail about Arya
about her family and about her whole
life which is something that the
faceless man had to do before they take
some space before they become that same
person before they become no.1 Arya with
proving that she will never be no.1
which she proved by hiding her sword
instead of giving it topped with all the
other things associated with her old
life by murdering someone without the
many-faced God's blessing and finally
failing purposely to assassinate lady
crane made Jack in regard to fulfill his
promise that he gave to the vase made
Jackie in Tula duvets kill area of its
only one order to kill her quickly
without suffering with all of this being
said the vase actually killed into
Carter's face it will explain jackets
final sentence that he said to Arya quit
by this theory actually the weight
bearing area space he said finally a
girl is no one something that Arya
surely didn't become so yeah Jackie
being proud dragons saying that a girl
has finally became no.1 might but only
might be referred to the waves as she
has also been trying to prove that she
can be no.1 and maybe by not just
killing Arya but also very girl's face
and becoming arya is the ultimate proof
that she finally became no.1 that she
finally accomplished
go also we should consider jackin smile
upon aria statement including a girl is
Arya Stark of Winterfell and I'm going
home which is something to think about
if this year is true if Arya is actually
bad and if the vase is varying her face
jogging could be happy because now she
has a reliable member of the faceless
man masquerading as Arya Stark which is
verse a great deal to the many-faced God
showrunners might have left out the
battle between the wife and Arya so they
could pull one of the greatest if not
the greatest place in the following
seasons which would once again providers
of shock something that made this
serious special among all the others
among those two theories that I
mentioned there's one more theory that
includes both of them includes Arya and
the waves according to this theory
oriented way for the same person with
the waves existing only Nargis mind the
ways would have been the no.1 the targa
had been trying to become at first this
might sound crazy but let's see the
clues that are apparently going favored
to this theory according to this theory
the biggest clue is in fact that only
aria in fermentor the face was mended
their space of floor attic criminal by
the name of jack and regard ever seem to
encounter the waves which is a little
bit strange this theory would also
explain why nobody intervened when two
vehicles beating a temporary blind arya
v to stake in the streets of Braavos
which a possibility of those passers-by
not intervened could be explained by a
fact that it could have led them to
death but not even to look at them
that's something that led me to believe
that the wave existed only nuria's mind
at least to believe in it for a few
moments as the theory continues we're
coming to the strongest
let's call it prove that goes in favor
to this theory which is the fact that
the vase knew absolutely everything
about Arya about her whole life a fact
that besides the serial suppose in favor
to a theory that I mentioned a few
minutes ago
theory in which the wave killed and
replaced Arya as a faceless man before
wearing someone's face firstly has to
learn absolutely everything about the
person which the faceless man intends to
replace and portray in conclusion all
those theories are more than interesting
every single one of them contains some
kind of proof but I'll let you decide
about accuracy of those three theories
and of course let me know in which one
you believe if you do in the comment
section down below do you think that it
was Arya herself who decided not to hide
virtue
identity by wearing someone's face as
she did in order to get a chance to
avenge her family to kill Walder Frey
same girl that was surprisingly calmly
walking around Bravo's famous locations
with huge amount of money without her
sword even though she knew that wave is
going after her which resulted with her
being stabbed multiple times or do you
think it was jacking her guard who
sacrificed himself in order to test ways
and in order to save Arya from a
possible slow death also give me your
thoughts about those two theories my
chair is actually dead well the wave is
varying her face and about a theory in
which the wave existed only Nora's mind
thank you for watching and don't forget
to participate in a new giveaway hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace
[Music]